You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够让我们迷失方向了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Before babies have the words to tell us what they're thinking, they can laugh. Infant giggles are undeniably adorable.
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是优惠，而不是惊喜时。住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。在婴儿还没学会用语言表达想法之前，他们会笑。婴儿的咯咯笑声无疑是可爱的。
They're one of babyhood's most joyful milestones. And it turns out these joyful moments have a serious side too. For scientists, infant laughter can provide a window into understanding how babies' minds develop during their first year of life. So when do babies start to laugh and why? What do they find funny? Why do some babies laugh at almost anything while others have a moment? more serious temperament. When do babies start trying to make other people laugh? And what can this
这是婴儿期最令人愉悦的里程碑之一。事实证明，这些快乐的时刻也有严肃的一面。对于科学家来说，婴儿的笑声可以为了解婴儿在生命第一年大脑如何发育提供一个窗口。那么，婴儿什么时候开始笑，为什么笑？他们觉得什么有趣？为什么有些婴儿几乎对什么都笑，而有些婴儿却表现得更严肃？婴儿什么时候开始尝试逗别人笑？这又说明了什么？
progression tell us about baby's cognitive development and how they experience the world? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Gina Moreau, a professor of psychology at Vermont State University, where she directs the infant laughter lab. She studies how babies discover what is funny, how they perceive, interpret, and respond to the unexpected in social contexts, revealing the earliest foundations of humor and social understanding.
这种发展过程告诉我们关于婴儿的认知发展以及他们如何体验世界的信息？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是佛蒙特州立大学心理学教授吉娜·莫罗博士，她在那里负责婴儿笑声实验室。她研究婴儿如何发现有趣的事物，如何感知、解释和回应社交环境中的意外，揭示了幽默和社会理解的最早基础。
Her research has been funded by the National Science Foundation and the National Institutes of Health and covered by media outlets including CNN.com, NBC Nightly News, and PBS's Nova Science Now. She recently wrote an op-ed for the New York Times, called the evolutionary brilliance of the baby giggle. Dr. Murrow, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me.
她的研究得到了美国国家科学基金会和美国国立卫生研究院的资助，并被 CNN.com、NBC 夜间新闻和 PBS 的《新星科学》等媒体报道。她最近为《纽约时报》撰写了一篇专栏文章，题为《婴儿咯咯笑的进化光辉》。莫罗博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。
Let's start with the basics. How early do babies start to smile and laugh? And does smiling come first or do both actions emerge around the same time? While smiling comes first, babies actually smile in utero. So it's an involuntary smile. And most parents will observe this smile when their babies are. brand new to the world. But these smiles are involuntary. They're not under the infant's control. They smile in their sleep. They smile indiscriminately at any kind of stimulus. And it's not until about
让我们从基础开始。婴儿多大开始微笑和笑？是先微笑还是两种动作同时出现？微笑先出现，婴儿实际上在子宫里就会微笑。所以这是一种非自愿的微笑。大多数父母会在宝宝刚来到这个世界时观察到这种微笑。但这些微笑是非自愿的。它们不受婴儿控制。他们在睡梦中微笑。他们不加选择地对任何刺激微笑。直到大约
six weeks, but babies vary quite a bit. So some babies will start to voluntarily smile earlier than that. But roughly about six weeks, babies can voluntarily smile. So they become much more discriminating. They like faces, for example. They might smile at the dog's face or at a lick from the dog or at mom or dad's voice or something like that. So six weeks, we see voluntary smiling. And then laughter for most babies who are on a typical developmental trajectory is at about four months. Some babies a little sooner than that. And some babies a little later.
六周大时，但婴儿之间差异很大。所以有些婴儿会比这更早开始自愿微笑。但大约在六周左右，婴儿可以自愿微笑。所以他们变得更有辨别力了。例如，他们喜欢人脸。他们可能会对着狗的脸、狗的舔舐，或者妈妈或爸爸的声音等微笑。所以六周时，我们看到了自愿微笑。对于大多数处于典型发育轨迹的婴儿来说，笑声大约在四个月时出现。有些婴儿会早一点，有些会晚一点。
And what are the earliest things that make babies laugh? So typically, babies will respond to funny noise. Noises, unexpected noises, and they also respond to touch. So tickling, for example. You know, my son's first laugh was at my brother's sneeze, which is a shocking sneeze. So it is a sneeze that will get your attention. And so it might be something like that, hearing a rooster crow or something that's really novel that they've never heard before. That will often do it for a brand new laugher. Now, in adults, we know that laughter is one way that we bond with other people. What purpose does laughter serve in babies? Is it the same for babies as it is for adults? We think so. I mean, I think one of the surprising things about laughter and smiling is that laughter in particular is that there's a really good research primarily initiated by Robert Provine at the University of Maryland, showing that laughter in adults rarely follows a joke. So it's not that we don't laugh at jokes, we do, but most of our laughter is in response to these benign social remarks, like, oh, I'm going to be late, ha, ha, ha, ha, or oh, I parked the car funny, ha, ha, ha, or something like that, like, or I can't find my keys. Ha, ha, ha. So these are odd things that we laugh at.
最早让婴儿发笑的是什么？通常，婴儿会对有趣的声音做出反应。噪音、意想不到的声音，他们也会对触摸做出反应。例如挠痒痒。你知道，我儿子的第一次笑是我哥哥打喷嚏时，那是一个令人震惊的喷嚏。所以这是一个会引起你注意的喷嚏。所以可能是类似的事情，听到公鸡打鸣或他们从未听过的新奇事物。这通常会让一个刚学会笑的婴儿笑出来。在成年人中，我们知道笑是我们与他人建立联系的一种方式。笑声在婴儿身上起什么作用？对婴儿和对成年人是一样的吗？我们认为是这样。我的意思是，我认为关于笑声和微笑的一件令人惊讶的事情是，特别是笑声，罗伯特·普罗文在马里兰大学进行的研究表明，成年人的笑声很少是在笑话之后出现的。所以并不是说我们不笑话，我们确实会笑，但我们大部分的笑声是对这些温和的社交言论的回应，比如，“哦，我要迟到了，哈哈哈哈”，或者“哦，我停车停得很有趣，哈哈哈哈”，或者类似的事情，或者“我找不到钥匙了，哈哈哈哈”。所以这些是我们会笑的奇怪事情。
But in keeping with Darwin's idea, Darwin was the first one to really write about infant laughter and his own child. The idea is that laughter and smiling is a social signal primarily. It serves a social purpose. First and foremost, we do share these kinds of signals with other mammals. So it does seem to communicate, I trust you. We are safe together. I enjoy your company, I like you, those kinds of things.
但按照达尔文的观点，达尔文是第一个真正写到婴儿笑声及其自身孩子的人。这个观点是，笑声和微笑主要是一种社交信号。它具有社交目的。首先，我们确实与其他哺乳动物分享这些信号。所以它似乎确实在传达：我信任你。我们在一起很安全。我喜欢你的陪伴，我喜欢你，诸如此类。
Understanding a joke is a cognitive exercise. You have to get why a joke is funny to laugh at it. But in your work, you found that infants as young as four to five months can distinguish between ordinary and incongruous events and they find incongruous things funny. Tell us about that work. Yeah, this still knocks my socks off. I mean, I think this is what I love about science is. science is so surprising whether you get the hypothesis right or not. There's always something there to unpack. So we really thought that this was kind of an open-and-shed case when we were trying to
理解一个笑话是一种认知练习。你必须明白为什么一个笑话好笑才会笑。但在你的工作中，你发现四到五个月大的婴儿就能区分普通事件和不协调事件，并且他们觉得不协调的事情很有趣。给我们讲讲那项工作。是的，这仍然让我感到震惊。我的意思是，我认为这就是我热爱科学的原因。科学是如此令人惊讶，无论你是否猜对了假设。总有一些东西可以挖掘。所以我们真的认为当我们试图
figure out why do babies or how do they figure out what's funny. And typically what happens is you know, parents are giving lots of cues when there are these absurd things going on. So the parent blows a raspberry on the baby's tummy and laughs and smiles in response. Are they pull their socks off and and wave them around and laugh and smile while they're doing that. And we thought, well, this is what's going on, you know. So we set up a little comedy club for babies in their homes. And we showed babies two different types of absurd events. One was taking a foam ball and putting it on the research assistant's nose.
弄清楚为什么婴儿或他们如何弄清楚什么是有趣的时，这是一个显而易见的问题。通常发生的情况是，你知道，当这些荒谬的事情发生时，父母会给出很多暗示。所以父母在宝宝的肚子上吹气，并做出回应，大笑和微笑。或者他们脱掉袜子，挥舞着它们，在做这些动作时大笑和微笑。我们想，好吧，这就是正在发生的事情。所以我们在他们家里为婴儿建立了一个小型的喜剧俱乐部。我们向婴儿展示了两种不同类型的荒谬事件。一种是拿一个泡沫球放在研究助理的鼻子上。
And the research assistant would poke their nose with their finger and say, beep, beep, beep, all with a straight face. The control event was the same foam ball that the researchers just passed back. and forth from hand to hand while they said a script. Like, this is a ball, it's red, it's squishy, something like that. And then we had parents do one of two things. So the parents never interacted with the infant. The infant could see the parent and the research assistant. And the infants were really poised so they could see the parents' reaction to the event.
研究助理会用手指戳他们的鼻子，说“哔，哔，哔”，全程面无表情。对照事件是研究人员只是把同样的泡沫球在手中传来传去，同时念着台词。比如，“这是一个球，它是红色的，它是软的”，诸如此类。然后我们让父母做两件事中的一件。父母从不与婴儿互动。婴儿可以看到父母和研究助理。婴儿们姿势很好，所以他们可以看到父母对事件的反应。
And so when the odd event was shown, like the ball is the clown nose, parents were instructed to either point and laugh at the clown nose, or or to simply look at it to not laugh or smile, just have a neutral face. And we really thought these six-month-olds would just find it funny when the parents found it funny. But that's not what we observed. So the six-month-olds were much more sophisticated than we thought. This is often the case when you're studying babies. And parents know this, grandparents know this, babies will surprise you at their level of sophistication.
所以当奇怪的事件出现时，比如球是小丑鼻子，父母被指示要么指着小丑鼻子大笑，要么只是看着它，不笑也不微笑，只是保持中立的表情。我们真的以为这些六个月大的婴儿只有在父母觉得有趣时才会觉得有趣。但我们观察到的并非如此。所以六个月大的婴儿比我们想象的要复杂得多。研究婴儿时经常会出现这种情况。父母知道这一点，祖父母也知道这一点，婴儿的复杂程度会让你大吃一惊。
So the six-linters were actually more likely to laugh at the event when the parents' stayed out of it. So they were decoding this event all by themselves as being silly. And it's still surprising to me that this is the case. Now, when do babies start trying to be funny themselves to produce humor rather than just laugh at something? And what does that say about their cognitive development at that point? It's such a great question. And what this question really gets at is intentionality. So when is it that babies intend to make somebody else laugh? And that can be a really tricky thing to get out experimentally. We also know that babies will accidentally make people laugh. So, for example, babies don't have a lot of good physical control over their bodies
所以六个月大的婴儿实际上更有可能在父母不参与时对事件发笑。所以他们完全是自己解码这个事件是愚蠢的。这对我来说仍然很惊讶。那么，婴儿什么时候开始尝试自己变得有趣，去制造幽默，而不仅仅是对某事发笑？这说明了他们当时的认知发展情况？这是一个非常好的问题。这个问题真正触及的是意图性。那么，婴儿什么时候打算逗别人笑呢？这在实验中可能是一个非常棘手的问题。我们也知道婴儿会无意中让人发笑。例如，婴儿对身体的物理控制能力并不强
in the first few months. So at three months or three and a half months, they might make a strange face or maybe their eyes are going in two different directions or something like that. It's not their fault. They just aren't myelinated yet. So parents might laugh at these odd things that babies are doing, which aren't under infants control. We're too conservative as scientists to attribute intentionality to that. What we do know, though, is that by about five months, babies do start to imitate odd actions. So, for example, if parents are just blowing raspberries, the baby, babies will typically have enough voluntary control to participate in that and to maybe imitate that as well. We've seen infants in our studies do this.
在最初的几个月里。所以三个月或三个半月时，他们可能会做一个奇怪的表情，或者他们的眼睛可能朝两个不同的方向看，诸如此类。这不是他们的错。他们只是还没有髓鞘化。所以父母可能会对婴儿做的这些奇怪的事情发笑，这些事情是不受婴儿控制的。作为科学家，我们太保守了，不能将其归因于意图性。然而，我们所知道的是，到五个月左右，婴儿确实开始模仿奇怪的动作。例如，如果父母只是吹气，婴儿通常会有足够的自愿控制能力来参与其中，并可能模仿它。我们在研究中看到婴儿这样做。
And parents, of course, will laugh at that. So I think it's a very dynamic process where babies figure out what gets the caregiver's attention and keeps it and is fun and enjoyable. Certainly by six months, babies are acting with intention. They will knock over a sibling's tower on purpose, for example. There's a great viral video on YouTube of a dad tearing paper, and the baby's sitting on the couch seems to be about six or seven months old, and the dad tears the paper, and the baby just cracks up, and it just can't contain themselves. And this is a good example of what we call violating construction.
当然，父母会对此发笑。所以我认为这是一个非常动态的过程，婴儿弄清楚什么能引起照顾者的注意，并保持这种注意，而且是有趣和令人愉快的。当然，到六个月时，婴儿是有意图地行动。例如，他们会故意推倒兄弟姐妹的塔。YouTube 上有一个很棒的病毒视频，一位父亲在撕纸，坐在沙发上的婴儿看起来大约六七个月大，父亲撕纸，婴儿就笑得前仰后合，无法自控。这就是我们所说的违反结构的一个很好的例子。
So this paper is supposed to be in a certain form, and the dad is destroying it, and we see infants start doing that at about six months of age, where they will violate. it can start you pop a bubble on purpose, for example, something like that. Will babies smile or laugh when they're alone? I think we know that adults don't tend to do this. That's a great question. There's just a little bit of research on this. There's just a little research in this area. So if anyone out there is thinking about a dissertation topic, lick me up. There is some work by Marianne LaFrance with 10-month-olds. And I don't remember exactly the experimental setup. But she did observe that infants were much less likely to smile when they
所以这张纸应该保持某种形式，而父亲正在破坏它，我们看到婴儿在大约六个月大时开始这样做，他们会违反。它可以开始，你故意戳破一个泡泡，例如，诸如此类。婴儿独自一人时会微笑或大笑吗？我想我们知道成年人通常不会这样做。这是一个很好的问题。这方面的研究很少。这方面的研究很少。所以如果有人在考虑论文题目，联系我。玛丽安·拉弗朗斯对 10 个月大的婴儿做了一些工作。我不记得确切的实验设置。但她确实观察到婴儿在
were by themselves and when there was a caregiver. And, you know, it doesn't take much. Like with babies that are about three months of age, our first study found that about 50% of three-month-olds would smile simply in response to a caregiver's smile. But by six months, only about five percent of babies would do that. So smiling alone is not quite enough. There is this cognitive piece that is involved a little bit later. But you're asking a really insightful question, which is that, yes, smiling does seem to be this social signal so that if you're by yourself, you know, you might as well reserve your smiling. What if a baby doesn't start laughing around five months or so? What does that indicate?
他们独自一人时比有照顾者在场时更不可能微笑。而且，你知道，不需要太多。对于大约三个月大的婴儿，我们的第一项研究发现，大约 50% 的三个月大的婴儿会仅仅为了回应照顾者的微笑而微笑。但到六个月时，只有大约 5% 的婴儿会这样做。所以独自微笑是不够的。稍后会涉及这个认知部分。但你问了一个非常有见地的问题，那就是，是的，微笑确实看起来是一种社交信号，所以如果你独自一人，你知道，你最好保留你的微笑。如果婴儿在五个月左右没有开始笑怎么办？这说明了什么？
And when should a parent be concerned? Yeah, it's a really good question. I'm not a pediatrician or a clinician, so I'm always a little bit hesitant. I get a lot of emails from parents who are worried. And, you know, I tend to think that parents should, and other caregivers should go on their gut instinct here. They have the best experience with their baby. They have the best frame of reference for what their infant does. Do they make eye contact, for example?
父母什么时候应该担心？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。我不是儿科医生或临床医生，所以我总是有点犹豫。我收到很多父母的电子邮件，他们很担心。而且，你知道，我倾向于认为父母和其他照顾者应该相信他们的直觉。他们对自己的宝宝有最好的经验。他们对婴儿的行为有最好的参考框架。例如，他们有眼神交流吗？
Do they like to be snuggled? Are they curious and investigating the environment? So is this lack of laughter sort of part of a bigger picture, or is it just this thing where it takes, you know, it takes more to get them to laugh? We've done one study looking at laughter at six months as a predictor of attachment at one year. And so this was a longitudinal study. And again, we were really surprised at the findings. We actually found that babies who had a higher threshold to laughing, so they, They weren't big laughers.
他们喜欢被拥抱吗？他们对环境好奇并进行探索吗？所以这种缺乏笑声是更大图景的一部分，还是仅仅需要更多的时间才能让他们笑？我们做了一项研究，观察六个月时的笑声作为一岁时依恋的预测指标。这是一项纵向研究。同样，我们对结果感到非常惊讶。我们实际上发现，笑声阈值较高的婴儿，也就是说，他们不是大笑者。
They weren't laughing with the frequency of some of their counterparts in our sample. They actually had a higher quality of attachment at 12 months. And it's very counterintuitive, but we think what was happening is that parents of these more sober babies had to work harder to get them to smile and to engage with them. And that this actually paid dividends for the babies in terms of attachment. Do you follow babies very far into their lives? I mean, like, do you know if you're looking at a baby at four or five months, do you ever see that same child at five and discover whether, you know, this kid's a stand-up comedian. He was very funny as a baby. We don't. It's hard enough to follow them for a couple of months. Babies are actually very hard to study because parents are so busy
他们的笑声频率不如我们样本中的一些同龄人。他们在 12 个月时实际上具有更高质量的依恋。这非常违反直觉，但我们认为发生的情况是，这些更严肃的婴儿的父母必须更加努力地让他们微笑并与他们互动。这对婴儿在依恋方面实际上产生了回报。你跟踪婴儿的生活很远吗？我的意思是，比如，如果你观察一个四五个月大的婴儿，你是否会在五岁时看到同一个孩子，并发现这个孩子是否是一个脱口秀演员？他小时候非常有趣。我们没有。跟踪他们几个月已经够难了。婴儿实际上很难研究，因为父母太忙了
and babies often are cutting teeth or they get sick or they just don't feel like participating in your study the day you need them to laugh. They're in a terrible mood. So we do well to follow them. You know, we've done only one study where we followed them from three months to 12 months. And it was incredibly laborious. We're glad we did it. But yet right now we're just doing some point in time studies. But we have done some from six to 12 months. Usually I don't go past that point. I have a great colleague at the University of Bristol in the UK who studies joke-telling and toddlers. So she sort of picks up where I left off or vice versa. Are there cultural differences or do all babies manifest humor at about the same time
而且婴儿经常长牙或生病，或者在你需要他们笑的那天他们只是不想参与你的研究。他们心情很糟糕。所以我们能跟踪他们就不错了。你知道，我们只做了一项研究，跟踪他们从三个月到 12 个月。这非常费力。我们很高兴我们做了。但目前我们只是在做一些时间点研究。但我们确实做了一些从六个月到 12 个月的。通常我不会超过那个点。我在英国布里斯托大学有一位很棒的同事，她研究幼儿讲笑话。所以她算是接手了我的工作，反之亦然。是否存在文化差异，还是所有婴儿在发育上大约在同一时间表现出幽默感
developmentally and in response to the same stimuli? We don't have great cross-cultural data. I mean, I tend to think about laughter and humor are separate. So laughter, I think we can think of as following a developmental trajectory. That's probably not culture-bound. It's kind of like walking and talking that these milestones tend to be hit at about the same ages unless there's some extreme intervention on part of the culture. There's a, for example, a culture where they use cradle boarding and babies are strapped to a cradle board while their parents work in the fields. And those babies are a little later to walk, but as soon as they're out of the cradle board, they're, you know, they catch right up with their peers. So I think we
并对相同的刺激做出反应？我们没有很好的跨文化数据。我的意思是，我倾向于认为笑声和幽默是分开的。所以笑声，我认为我们可以认为它遵循一个发育轨迹。这可能不是文化限制的。这有点像走路和说话，这些里程碑往往在相同的年龄达到，除非文化方面有某种极端的干预。例如，有一种文化，他们使用摇篮板，婴儿在父母在地里工作时被绑在摇篮板上。这些婴儿走路稍晚一些，但一旦他们离开摇篮板，他们就会赶上同龄人。所以我认为我们
can think of laughter as being not culture-bound, humor might be, and that might also include the culture of the family, not just the culture of the country or the nation. So I think about the type of things that kids are allowed to laugh at, for example. In my own family, we tend to say we have very dark humor, and our kids who are now adults had and still have very dark humor. And we saw that from them at very early ages. And we even wondered as parents were both psychologists. Is that okay? But we decided we had other things to worry about. So I think that humor specifically is probably, probably is culture bound. And the culture can be a microculture of the family or, you know, our community, for example. We're going to take a short break. When we get back,
可以认为笑声不是文化限制的，幽默可能是，这也可能包括家庭文化，而不仅仅是国家或民族的文化。所以我想到孩子们被允许笑的事情类型，例如。在我自己的家庭中，我们倾向于说我们有非常黑暗的幽默感，我们的孩子现在是成年人了，他们过去和现在仍然有非常黑暗的幽默感。我们在他们很小的时候就看到了这一点。作为父母，我们甚至想过，我们都是心理学家。这可以吗？但我们决定我们还有其他事情要担心。所以我认为幽默具体来说可能是文化限制的。文化可以是家庭的微文化，或者我们的社区，例如。我们要休息一下。回来后，
we'll talk about whether there are any surefire jokes that make all babies laugh. It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today.
我们将讨论是否有任何万无一失的笑话能让所有婴儿发笑。现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意扩展很快。为了保持花蜜流动，我需要一个具有最高优先级数据速度的电话套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢嗡嗡作响时，我的连接也保持强劲。此外，无限套餐每月 35 美元起。这真是一个不会停留的交易。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。
Plus taxes and government fees. GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot.
外加税费和政府费用。Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不受数据流量降级的影响。你的夏天从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用汉普顿湾 West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。
While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Is there any one thing that all babies find funny, like peekaboo? Well, I never like to say all, but I think peekaboo is a great guess. If you are, you know, traveling on public transportation and there's an infant whose parent really needs a break, then I think peekaboo is a great go-to. And babies in the four to six-month-old age range, our pediatrician used to say they have a social agenda. I love that description, that they are so engaged by other people for the most part.
售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/price-match。有没有什么东西是所有婴儿都觉得有趣的，比如躲猫猫？嗯，我从不喜欢说“所有”，但我认为躲猫猫是一个很好的猜测。如果你在公共交通工具上旅行，有一个婴儿的父母真的需要休息，那么我认为躲猫猫是一个很好的选择。在四到六个月大的婴儿中，我们的儿科医生过去常说他们有社交议程。我喜欢这个描述，他们大部分时间都被其他人所吸引。
They might find almost anything you offer them to be worthy of a smile, if not a laugh. Peekaboo is great. Tickling tends to be a universal crowd pleaser for infants. Certainly infants under about seven or eight months, they like it. We do know that as babies get older, for example, even at by six months, babies will find peekaboo entertaining for a very short period of time and then you need to work harder for it to keep them engaged. So they start doing something fascinating at that point, which is something called polite laughter, which is also sometimes referred to as fake laughter. So I don't like fake because it sounds manipulative, but that is what
他们可能会发现你提供给他们的几乎任何东西都值得微笑，如果不是大笑的话。躲猫猫很棒。挠痒痒往往是婴儿普遍喜欢的。当然，七八个月以下的婴儿喜欢它。我们确实知道，随着婴儿长大，例如，即使在六个月大时，婴儿也会觉得躲猫猫在很短的时间内很有趣，然后你需要更努力地让他们保持参与。所以他们在那个时候开始做一些迷人的事情，这叫做礼貌性笑声，有时也被称为假笑。所以我不喜欢“假”这个词，因为它听起来很操纵，但这就是
it's called in the literature. So this just means that adults do this too. If we, you know, somebody tells a joke and we think it's kind of funny, we might go, you know, something like that. where we want to communicate like we really like you and we really want to stay in this conversation with you, but you got to do better. Six-month-olds can do that. Yeah. What about other mammals? Other mammals smile and laugh like human babies? Yeah, they do. And this is so amazing, particularly juveniles. So most of this work, there's some good work in comparative psychology looking at this in other non-human primates. But I think some of the most fascinating work was by Yak-Penck. who just passed away within the last couple of years. He was a neuroscientist and he studied rats
它在文献中的称呼。所以这意味着成年人也会这样做。如果我们，你知道，有人讲了一个笑话，我们觉得它有点好笑，我们可能会说，你知道，类似的事情。我们想传达我们真的很喜欢你，我们真的很想继续和你谈话，但你得做得更好。六个月大的婴儿能做到这一点。是的。其他哺乳动物呢？其他哺乳动物像人类婴儿一样微笑和发笑吗？是的，他们会。这太神奇了，尤其是幼崽。所以大部分工作，在比较心理学中有一些很好的工作在研究其他非人类灵长类动物的这一点。但我认为一些最迷人的工作是由雅克·潘克塞普完成的，他就在过去几年内去世了。他是一位神经科学家，他研究老鼠
and found kind of by accident that when you tickle rats, he studied emotions. So there was a reason for him to be doing this. When you tickle rats, they actually chirp and they chirp at a very high frequency. So it's not available to the human ear. You have to have specialized equipment to hear it. But their chirping is at a similar cadence to human laughter. For listeners who have dogs, dogs are a great example. If you listen to dogs when they're playing, they do what's called play panting. And it sounds kind of like a chimp. So they go, they only do this on the exhale. But anyway, dogs do this and other mammals do as well. So again, this kind of gives some real leverage to Darwin's argument, what Panksyp discovered, he may not be the first to discover this, but I can
并偶然发现当你挠老鼠时，他研究情绪。所以他这样做是有原因的。当你挠老鼠时，它们实际上会发出啁啾声，而且它们以非常高的频率发出啁啾声。所以人耳听不到。你必须有专门的设备才能听到它。但它们的啁啾声与人类笑声的节奏相似。对于有狗的听众来说，狗是一个很好的例子。如果你听狗玩耍时，它们会做所谓的“玩耍喘气”。听起来有点像黑猩猩。所以它们发出声音，它们只在呼气时这样做。但无论如何，狗会这样做，其他哺乳动物也会。所以再次，这为达尔文的论点提供了一些真正的杠杆作用，潘克塞普发现的，他可能不是第一个发现这一点的人，但我可以
credit it to him with confidence, is that other mammals have all the same brain structures of the limbic system, which we have. So all mammals show those same structures, and that suggests that emotion, joy, sadness, some of the primary emotions did not just bubble up in humans, that these have been there and they're part of our evolutionary ancestry. So we're not necessarily projecting onto our pets that they're laughing. They may actually be laughing in their own way. I live with a very funny dog. Yeah, I think, you know, we have to be careful about that.
自信地归功于他，那就是其他哺乳动物拥有我们所拥有的边缘系统的所有相同大脑结构。所以所有哺乳动物都表现出这些相同的结构，这表明情绪、快乐、悲伤、一些基本情绪不仅仅是在人类中冒出来的，这些情绪一直存在，并且是我们进化祖先的一部分。所以我们不一定是在把它们投射到我们的宠物身上，认为它们在笑。它们可能确实在以自己的方式笑。我和一只非常有趣的狗住在一起。是的，我想，你知道，我们必须小心
that rate that we're not just projecting. Although Panksep actually made the argument that we should, that to try to remove ourselves from the other mammalian experience is really inhumane, and it's a scientific or non-scientific. That to understand other emotional experience, we should try to relate it to our own experience. This was not necessarily a popular argument. It was a very controversial argument to make, but it's an interesting one to entertain. So how did you get interested in studying humor in babies and has it been challenging for you? I mean, you've got a lab, but getting funding for the kind of research you do, which some people might say is frivolous. Yeah, absolutely. So for about 15 years, I studied loss. I studied early loss in childhood.
那个比率，我们不仅仅是在投射。尽管潘克塞普实际上提出了一个论点，即我们应该这样做，试图将我们自己从其他哺乳动物的体验中剥离出来是非常不人道的，而且是科学的或非科学的。为了理解其他情感体验，我们应该尝试将其与我们自己的体验联系起来。这不一定是一个受欢迎的论点。这是一个非常有争议的论点，但这是一个值得考虑的有趣论点。那么你是怎么对研究婴儿幽默感感兴趣的，这对你来说有挑战性吗？我的意思是，你有一个实验室，但为你所做的研究获得资金，有些人可能会说这是轻浮的。是的，绝对。所以大约 15 年来，我研究失落。我研究童年早期的失落。
And at the beginning of that line of research, I had a baby. And I had never, my son's, my first born, and I had never even changed a diaper. It's a shock that they let me leave the hospital with him. We had no experience. But anyway, it was, so I was really having this front seat experience with him as a mom. And he started laughing to my brother's sneeze when he was about three and a half months old. And, you know, when you're a psychologist, you just can't help but observe behavior. It's just kind of an occupational hazard.
在那条研究路线的开始，我生了一个孩子。我从来没有，我儿子的，我的第一个孩子，我甚至从来没有换过尿布。他们让我带着他离开医院真是令人震惊。我们没有任何经验。但无论如何，作为妈妈，我真的和他有了这种前排的体验。当他大约三个半月大时，他开始对我哥哥的喷嚏发笑。而且，你知道，当你是一名心理学家时，你忍不住观察行为。这只是一种职业危害。
And I remember being so shocked that he was laughing and really amused and entertained by this. And I thought, what is that? Why? Why do infants laugh? I knew that they laughed. I just never asked the question why. So it was about, he was 13 when I took a sabbatical and switched my research focus and went and studied in the UK with my colleague now, good friend, Vasu Reddy.
我记得当时非常震惊，他竟然在笑，而且真的被这个逗乐了。我想，那是什么？为什么？为什么婴儿会笑？我知道他们会笑。我只是从来没有问过为什么。所以大约在他 13 岁时，我休了学术假，改变了我的研究重点，去英国和我现在的同事、好朋友瓦苏·雷迪一起学习。
And it was at that point I had to apply for funding. So I was really worried that this would be seen as a frivolous line of research. I applied for some funding within my state in Vermont. We have this nice mechanism that is through an NIH-Inbri grant, so that little colleges don't have to compete with the big colleges for money. So I got a little grant and collected some data with my students. And then I went to a big infancy conference to present it, and I was very, very nervous.
就在那时，我不得不申请资金。所以我真的很担心这会被视为一项轻浮的研究。我在佛蒙特州内申请了一些资金。我们有一个很好的机制，是通过 NIH-Inbri 拨款，这样小学院就不必与大学院竞争资金。所以我得到了一小笔拨款，并和我的学生收集了一些数据。然后我去了一个大型婴儿会议展示它，我非常非常紧张。
And the very first response I got, I was just doing a poster because it was some preliminary data. Another scientist approached me. And she said, oh, my gosh, you study laughing? Oh, I studied crying. And she was so filled with regret. And, you know, she really, she just gave me this sense of real relief and validation that, okay, it's going to be okay. She was fascinated in the study.
我得到的第一个回应，我只是在做一个海报，因为那是一些初步数据。另一位科学家走近我。她说，天哪，你研究笑？哦，我研究哭。她充满了遗憾。而且，你知道，她真的给了我一种真正的解脱感和认可感，好吧，没关系。她对这项研究很着迷。
So from that point on, I was never concerned. And the work has been wonderfully received everywhere that I've presented it, or my students have presented it. In terms of getting funding, I will say that I don't use the words humor. I don't use. We do say that we measure laughter. But, you know, it's what we're really studying was something you were getting at earlier on in this conversation, which is that we're studying something cognitive here. So we're interested in this cognitive skill and whether or not infants have it. And that is
所以从那时起，我再也没有担心过。这项工作在我展示它的任何地方，或者我的学生展示它的地方，都受到了极好的欢迎。在获得资金方面，我会说我不使用“幽默”这个词。我不使用。我们确实说我们测量笑声。但是，你知道，我们真正研究的是你在这次谈话中早些时候提到的东西，那就是我们在这里研究的是认知方面的东西。所以我们对这种认知技能以及婴儿是否具备它感兴趣。而这
really their ability to detect incongruity, which means an unusual or unexpected event, and to appraise it. And what are they using in their environment to appraise it? So that's the language that we use in funding. So what are you studying now? What are the big questions that you're still trying to answer? Yeah. So we just finished up a study. We have manuscript in revision. Fingers crossed. That's all done pretty soon. One of the questions that I was really intrigued by was how infants differentiate
确实是他们检测不协调的能力，这意味着一种不寻常或意想不到的事件，并对其进行评估。他们利用环境中的什么来评估它？这就是我们在资金申请中使用的语言。那么你现在在研究什么？你还在试图回答哪些大问题？是的。所以我们刚刚完成了一项研究。我们有手稿在修改中。祈祷吧。那很快就完成了。我真正感兴趣的问题之一是婴儿如何区分
different types of incongruities. So there's a big body of literature that looks at magical incongruities. These are impossible events like a ball floating in the air, for example, or an object turning into another object. So we call them magical because these are kind of impossible events. And there's a whole wonderful body of literature that shows that starting at about three and a half months of age, babies stare at those events when you compare those to control events. So they're really captivated by them. And then in my line of research, which is like four people doing this work, we show babies incongruities, but they're silly incongruities. So the question that we've just gone after is how do babies distinguish these types of events, you know, can they? And what we did in this last study was we presented babies with magical incongruities, but we put them in different contexts.
不同类型的不协调。有一个庞大的文献体系研究神奇的不协调。这些是不可能的事件，例如球在空中漂浮，或者物体变成另一个物体。所以我们称它们为神奇的，因为这些是某种不可能的事件。有一个完整而精彩的文献体系表明，从三个半月大开始，当将这些事件与对照事件进行比较时，婴儿会盯着这些事件看。所以他们真的被它们吸引住了。然后在我的研究路线中，就像有四个人在做这项工作，我们向婴儿展示不协调，但它们是愚蠢的不协调。所以我们刚刚追求的问题是婴儿如何区分这些类型的事件，你知道，他们能吗？我们在最后这项研究中所做的是，我们向婴儿展示了神奇的不协调，但我们将它们放在不同的环境中。
In the magic literature, babies just see the events. They don't see a person. They just see hands or they see a theater or a screen where the events are unfolding in an asocial context. So all we did was take two magic tricks and we put them in a social context. We had a magician perform the events. They did not interact with the babies. And babies were much more likely to smile at these events. They actually did not look longer at these events, which contradicts this other body of literature.
在魔法文献中，婴儿只是看到事件。他们看不到人。他们只是看到手，或者他们看到一个剧院或屏幕，事件在非社交环境中展开。所以我们所做的只是拿两个魔术，把它们放在社交环境中。我们让魔术师表演这些事件。他们没有与婴儿互动。婴儿更有可能对这些事件微笑。他们实际上并没有在这些事件上花费更长的时间，这与另一部分文献相矛盾。
But it's one study. It's in a naturalistic context. It needs to be replicated. But it is interesting to think that, you know, infants are really, really picking on the social environment and that they're deriving meaning about events just based on the presence of another person. And it could be, it could be that they're attributing intentionality, like, oh, that person meant to do that. And that lets them resolve the incongruity, which is like getting the punchline. Like, oh, that's what you meant.
但这只是一项研究。它是在自然主义的环境中。它需要被复制。但想到婴儿真的真的在关注社交环境，并且他们仅仅基于另一个人的存在就推导出关于事件的意义，这很有趣。而且可能是，他们可能在归因意图性，比如，哦，那个人是故意那样做的。这让他们解决了不协调，就像得到笑话的梗概一样。比如，哦，这就是你的意思。
That's funny, you know. So I'm just working on our next study with a brilliant colleague, John Lane, at Vanderbilt. He's been a consultant on this current study. And we're thinking about putting this question of intentionality really to the test and showing infants magic tricks where the magician will use a technique that, again, Elena Hoika at the UK Bristol University has used, where infants hear one of two verbal cues, they either hear the magician say, uh-oh, like this was a mistake or, ha-ha, like I meant to do that, and seeing if infants can use those cues to understand the intentionality of the magician in one condition, and whether or not
这很有趣，你知道。所以我正在和范德比尔特大学一位出色的同事约翰·莱恩一起进行我们的下一项研究。他一直是这项当前研究的顾问。我们正在考虑真正测试意图性这个问题，并向婴儿展示魔术，魔术师将使用一种技术，同样，英国布里斯托大学的埃琳娜·霍伊卡使用过这种技术，婴儿听到两个口头暗示中的一个，他们要么听到魔术师说，“哎呀”，就像这是一个错误，或者“哈哈”，就像我是故意那样做的，看看婴儿是否能利用这些暗示来理解魔术师在一种情况下的意图，以及他们是否
they'll be more likely to laugh in response or smile. So Elena's done something like that with older toddlers. So we'd really be scaling it back for babies. Well, Dr. Moreau, I want to thank you for joining me today. This was really a lot of fun and got me laughing too. Oh, great, great. Well, that's always a great success. Thank you so much for your interest.
更有可能做出回应而发笑或微笑。所以埃琳娜对年龄较大的幼儿做过类似的事情。所以我们真的会为婴儿缩小规模。好吧，莫罗博士，我想感谢您今天加入我的节目。这真的很有趣，也让我笑了。哦，太棒了，太棒了。好吧，那总是一个巨大的成功。非常感谢您的兴趣。
I really appreciate it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save
我真的很感激。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的剧集有评论或想法，你可以通过 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 给我们发电子邮件。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价。当你下载应用程序时，你可以每周通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，你可以赚取燃油积分以节省
up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在加油站每加仑最高 1 美元。在 Ralph's，你每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。所以每天通过储蓄和奖励来节省大笔开支总是很容易的。Ralph's SoCal 超过 150 年。储蓄可能因州而异。适用燃油限制。详情请参阅网站。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。